i gotta ask though what is your creative
process behind how you like make your
videos how do you get like your video
ideas from man because you have like
some of the craziest [ __ ] video ideas
i think on the platform yeah i don't
know this happens
like it happens very rarely so it's like
probably the most annoying [ __ ] is like
with an idea that i think is good yeah
that i like would have fun doing yeah um
that's probably why it takes so long to
make videos yeah i don't know i just
like will be doing something and i'd be
like this i could make this way more
complicated and stupid do you have like
a short list of ideas of like things you
like might want to pursue yeah i got a
couple of them i got yeah i had a yeah i
do have a short list of ideas but a lot
of them are like maybes i think one is
like yeah a lot of them are like
dependent on if it will work i think one
is like a meat roomba a roomba made of
meat
[Music]
and i had like a baby killing drone idea
but that one
i
i didn't end up doing that do you want
to expand upon that one
yeah
um it's like a drone yeah that would
like uh it would kill babies like with
lego pieces like choking hazard like no
oh the pneumatic spike on the drone and
it would find it would the idea was to
don't tell the us government they're
going to try and get that technology
yeah
they need that
have you ever had like an idea that
you've started working on because like
it takes you like [ __ ] months to do
it so i can't imagine being you're in
your position where you have to like
commit to one idea and you like need to
commit to this for months yeah i i try
to validate it as fast as i can because
if it doesn't if it isn't good then i'll
like you know shoot it and just not do
it
i'll kill it uh because it's just not
available so i like try to get like um
like in the beginning i'll like try to
get as much done on like the tech side
of stuff to just like validate like okay
this is gonna work to the end of the
video and then i'll like start the video
and it'll be like halfway done i'll do
it like in the middle and stuff but i
get to a point where i'm like okay the
video will work because i don't wanna
start filming and then i'm like this
isn't gonna work yeah yeah what like
percentage of ideas do you scrap would
you say um i don't know uh
usually i'm pretty good at not
trying like pursuing saying this yeah
yeah yeah i'm good at like killing it
before i even like try to do it yeah
usually um yeah so i just shoot down
like ninety percent of like what's the
what's the video that took you the
longest from like start to finish oh
um
the like longest in time yeah probably
like the the that the uh like the beer
pissing dog video i made
that took a little pretty long that or
the um the surgery robot was really
intense yeah yeah
um i spent a lot of time like i had a
really good time working on that was one
of my favorite ones yeah because it was
like good work every day like i would
always like some progress yeah i'd wake
up and i'd be like okay these 3d printed
parts don't fit together so good i'll
print it out tomorrow and i wake up they
get down off the printer and then like
sit in my garage listen to music and
like the door would be open yeah and i'd
like have everything working and that
one went pretty well yeah it just took a
really long time to like get everything
down for that right yeah that was a
great one i really like sounds like tony
stark or something like that
so like that that thing wasn't small
what are you doing with all this stuff
oh so that dude i uh well that one i
used a little bit for stream so
i i like attached a camera to it and um
to where the knife was yeah and i used
like a i instead of the hand thing it's
like ps3 controller yeah and i just
moved around so people could see what i
was doing on the table when i was
streaming
um but then when i moved i was just like
i i like cut it up and took all the
electronics and all the good bits and
just threw the rest away yeah yeah that
one was way too [ __ ] big i was gonna
say i'm like you can't just have like a
storeroom
your museum
i have some of my [ __ ] in like a
storeroom somewhere i imagine if it's
like practical you're like i can keep
the roomba yeah yeah yeah it's small too
it's like an easy kind of yeah have you
ever come close like injuring yourself
because like i see some of your [ __ ]
inventions i'm like this is a couple
times usually electrocution is like the
main concern that's just not actual
that's just a normal thing right a lot i
mean i've never heard i like taste or
anything it's been a while since oh
really no i shouldn't say that should i
why did you like perk up it's not as bad
i think everyone should know at least
it doesn't look that bad because
everyone seems okay after it yeah like i
mean it's really weird because it's like
it hurts really bad but it's not like
getting hit where it hurts for a while
because it hurts really bad and then not
at all
[Applause]
neither of us have been tased so yeah
yeah
and there's a difference between like
stun gun tasers like that you get on
amazon and like you always take
difference yeah like a police tape
tasers like you probably shouldn't do
that yeah i'm not gagging over it
i'm like i'm good
if i don't did you ever watch what's uh
was it coyote penis
well when i was a kid i did get the
mains of my house across the chest
through the heart wow um okay so i like
i wasn't super
good at any of that stuff so but i knew
electricity
like well no like like since i was like
maybe 14 like vaguely because we had a
lot of trash around our house yeah super
villain all superhero artists like i
would just like get a bunch of batteries
and swim together and the wires would
heat up and be like that's sweet and
then i was like dude we have electricity
in the walls
why am i messing with batteries and so
you gotta pay for duration for that [ __ ]
i would just cut like like a cord a
power cord and just cut it and then get
the two wires and i would just flick
them together and in like stranded wires
instantly like uh especially if it's
like thin stranded
in a bunch of sparks and molten copper
everywhere and it's really cool and so i
was like [ __ ] the the copper is like
getting all messed up so i soldered like
or not solder i probably just twisted
the wire and hot glue yeah that was my
soldering forever yeah was twisting the
wire on metal and hot glue no yeah dude
like even into many youtube videos
so i twisted that and i was like
tapping that and i don't know i just
touched the bottom and then like got the
got through the chat [ __ ] you up like no
i mean well you don't do it yeah yeah
yeah yeah because you would not
recommend this yeah and you would you
would super die in the in super giant
in japan 240 voltage oh yeah
no wait no wait uh it's 220 right yeah
220 222 it's 240 in the uk right yeah
the uk
even better and so that's
that's like four times yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] i get scared watching um
electro booms videos yeah
yeah he just always trips wise and stuff
i know he knows what he's doing i think
i don't know he seems like he knows i
think yeah i don't know but he did one
video where he went to the uk yeah and
he was in a hotel room yeah and uh he
just he tries to like short the means
and he just [ __ ] the whole wall is
black
like the whole thing yeah he's like oh
this this mains in the hotel is not that
good in the uk i'm like what the [ __ ]
can just go to a hotel and do that dude
he did it in hawaii too he i i know he
does it i know why he does it he goes
and does it so he can tax right off the
vacation for his family
yeah yeah so this is like a kind of
thing i think i assume he's an engineer
i really agree
yeah he's very knowledgeable
yeah i've seen some of his videos he
shocks himself quite often literally
i think usually it's control i think the
one that was scary was his jacob's
ladder video for like a million oh that
was [ __ ] scary yeah because that
one's like like with 220 or like maine's
in a house it's like you you you
probably won't die but like obviously
there's a chance you will yeah but
there's like it's not guaranteed but
like the jacob's ladder it's like 16 000
volts it's like instant death yeah you
touched it yeah through the chest and
his he was like celebrating some
subscriber milestone is going up and
like he kicked the wire and it fell
towards him yeah i saw that i don't know
how he like managed to get out of the
way because that [ __ ] has to be instant
death yeah yeah
i just can't believe how reckless he is
you should watch it it's very
i just yeah understand people who are
okay around livewire well i mean if
you're if you've probably studied it
your whole life you probably feel a bit
more comfortable probably not a good
idea still but yeah you know
i can understand why he'd be like i know
exactly how all this works yeah i've got
that what's the what's it called america
the thing where if you electric yourself
the plug flips yeah it's got the gfci um
yeah yeah
i gotta break ground breakers
yeah breakers yeah all our plugs have
the fuses in them right yeah yeah yeah
yeah and the fuel as well that's pretty
smart well yeah but then the [ __ ]
annoying ones that we should we've got
like the three-pronged ones which is
just like it's so much bigger than any
other plug it's huge it's [ __ ]
massive right but uh but every plug has
a fuse in it yeah like and you can
change it oh yeah it's really nice it's
quite smart yeah you don't have to worry
about it so is that where your obsession
with getting electrocuted started at a
young age
or electrocuting other people you want
to like you want them to experience what
you're experiencing insane i don't know
were you that kid that stuck the fork in
the socket
you're the reason why we have those like
things on the uh
please don't electrify the legos they do
not survive
all right not gonna do that